my name is John Russell ttyn I'm an
owner and distiller here at new Columbia
distillers the maker of green hat gym I
wanted people to make a connection not
everybody who buys a bottle of this or
sees a bottle of this is going to go to
the website and I really wanted them to
be able to at least understand why it's
called green hat that was the reason
behind having this one of the reasons
behind having this story on the side the
man in the green hat is George Cassidy
he was the chief bootlegger to Congress
during Prohibition they actually give
him an office for the first five years
1920 to 1925 he works out of the cannon
house office building and then in 1925
he got arrested and had a very very
brief jail sentence and then shifted
over to the Senate side and he worked
for five years out of the the Russell
Senate office building I think he felt
he was a respectable businessman that
was doing business kind of on the side
and that he didn't need to worry about
it as long as he didn't go into the you
know other areas there's never a violent
felon he never carried a gun he never
had reason to write so he was in essence
a great example of civil disobedience
and also someone who was simply
supplying the market for what the market
wanted you know including the
congressman I believe they arrested him
held in the parking lot and at that time
he was actually wearing this green
fedora and there was a reporter in
nearby who simply pointed him out it was
that man over there in the green hat and
the nickname stuck he pretty much got
off when that initial charge but it
soured him so much because basically he
felt like he had been kind of ready to
help somebody on the house side and so
he went over into the Senate who knew
him very well and they provide him with
an office back then nobody searched you
when you came into the office they only
searched do when he left and so it was
very very easy for him to bring his
suitcase with him every day and just
resupply his office so Cassidy would
leave every day with this empty suitcase
they would open it up and
there's nothing in it congressman by the
way they were never searched that was
part of their privilege they could leave
the office with all the booze they
wanted and no one would ever to check
their suitcase and cassadee by the way
was not the only bootleggers operating
there were other bootleggers as well but
he was he seemed to have a good chunk of
the market share and he was also the
only one to come forward to dispel the
beans afterwards when Cassidy was
arrested for the second time in February
1930 he essentially reached a plea
agreement with the judge of whereby he
agreed not to bootleg anymore and he was
good to his word on that and in October
1930 he published five front page
articles in The Washington Post it was
called the man in the green hat series
and basically he outlined all the
details of his operation then people saw
how hypocritical it was for Congress to
participate in the consumption of
alcohol well at the same time standing
on the house floor of the Senate
denouncing issues and making it illegal
for anyone else to drink them with this
people were just absolutely done with
with the DRI cause at that point and so
when the election happened then just a
week later Congress shifted from being
this ostensibly dry Republican majority
to becoming an openly wet Democratic
majority with that and cassadee largely
disappears from the public eye and you
know here we are three or four
generations later and we look back and
think wow it really it's quite a
remarkable story what this guy did I
think he would actually feel proud and
and tickled to see you know his his name
being talked about that he's getting
some kind of recognition for doing
something may have been pretty good you
know if he had even the smallest little
bit getting prohibition appeal
and you know I I'm very proud of that I
think it's great that we can tell his
story we really like the name cuz I mean
we looked at a lot of things and I don't
think in distilleries after us we'll be
able to get is good a story as we came
up with you know I'm trying to figure
out what we're gonna name our next
products luckily it's gonna be risky and
it won't come out for three to five
years so we've got a little time but
it's it's gonna be hard